then talk a little bit about when you
actually went out on your own kind of
why go out on your own and what were
some of the things you learned as you
did that um I thought you know that I
was avoiding FOMO partially right we
went Centaurus top ranked wheelie who
now runs copper wood and I were gonna
partner together right I being the
second most successful trader at Copper
wood and a bunch of other all-stars is
they're all officers you know he's going
to start the fun and the bottom line is
this Greg and I could not agree on on
control wrist limits etc rightly Greg's
Greg's a military guy he's got he can
only be one captain right and so even
though we're we're great friends and we
still talk a lot it was better for me to
go away and the reason why is the
pooling risk in commodities you know
guys wanted me to stay for you know
having my set of neurons and my way of
thinking to help the fun but I was like
listen you could have your best year
ever and I could wipe you out right
because if I have a bad year I trade
such a big you know big book big style
you kind of want to be insulated from
that you think you want me but you don't
want it you know and we can always talk
shop right so you still get my neurons
right but you you don't you don't you
don't have the risk and so that's the
way it went got it and then when you
went out on your own you went right to
to all the energy stuff for retraining
other commodities as well know is just
to treat what I know right like it would
be hard it would be very very hard for
us for me to raise money outside of you
know what I had been doing then it's
raising money so we were able to get you
know a big check from one institution
ambassador of fund of funds and and
we're still small teeny teeny fine but
and a couple other friends and family
and high-net-worth individuals for sure
and then as you've grown I think you're
also doing venture capital investing now
as well a little bit
yeah I do that through drew my own
entity right I have enough capital to be
like I guess a medium-sized family
office and so I have a lot of in-house
expertise that I've hired over the years
to attack certain certain problems deal
with certain issues and so I have a CIO
I have you know capital to deploy and I
love solving puzzles so I've been doing
that um I don't aside but it's not on
the side at the size we're doing it you
know I say it on the side because my
primary job is training natural gas and
training training energy but you know we
rewrite what I would consider so what's
significant tickets you know when I go
into you know a publicly listed stock
and I look at how many shares I hold and
I'm like wow we're in the top if they
listen to us we'd be in the top top ten
right of shares you know and so and when
we come into a private placement you
know we're able to write the tickets
that people are looking for and the size
is right they don't want one single
investor to control it but they're
looking for half a million two million
to five million blocks you know we're
able to write that ticket so it's it's
gotten pretty serious you know it's
always serious right but it's gotten
it's significant
the unfortunate thing is is though we do
have a limited pool of capital and
there's lots of great things